it was the State of the Union last night
Barack Obama's fifth State of the Union
we thought it might be six but they
don't do one like two days after the
inauguration so it was his fifth State
of the Union last night and they pretty
much covered the whole damn thing we're
just gonna show you one little video
clip here I like this when he was
talking about equal pay for women and
then of course the cameras have to show
you women cuz how else would you know
what women look like if they didn't show
you they're talking about them let's
glue yes today women make up about half
our workforce but they still make 77
cents for every dollar a man earns that
is wrong and in 2014 it's an
embarrassment women deserve equal pay
for equal work
that's right women and we've got women
right here now those women all do get
equal pay for equal work because they're
in the Congress of a Senate and so on so
I always think things like that are the
funny things really because without you
know we'll get into some of the
substance but don't you think like the
way they shoot it and you know if you
talk about a black person you have to
show a black person quick show a black
person yeah there you go shows for this
I always remember like one year that
Pedro almodóvar won an Oscar and they
had oh my god find a Hispanic Gloria
Estefan great yes her you know that my
favorite being with Jodie Foster's super
awkward coming out speech at last year's
Golden Globes and they kept took Jane
Lynch kind of going am I being insulted
right now so that has clearly bled into
now the c-span coverage yeah for sure I
think I think there's a you know awkward
moments are underrated I love them so
what I always hope for when they show
these folks and they shoot them you know
you expect all the women stand up the
applauding and then give the standing
ovation
one of them to go why wasn't Hillary
there now I know she's not working for
the administration at the moment but
you'd think she'd show up or at least
get an invite to something of this
nature you know that she is very
casually lying low she is here this
whole year is it about like it's sort of
like how Anne Hathaway went away you
know she is sort of waiting making us
want her back figuring out what her next
move is gonna be hedging her bets you
know so she's very shrewdly making
herself at realize that even opponents
that are gonna you know be fighting
against her for 2016 is there they're
trying to keep her relevant only in the
negative tones they really bring up in
God's every once in a while and say yeah
like they once every once in a while
they want us they want to splatter it in
because she really is I really think
you're right but she's laying low
thinking when I come back oh it's a good
plan as far as the regular American
mindset yeah exactly by the way her
Hillary ready for 2016
Twitter account is verified which I'm
pretty sure means she's running for
president in case there's any doubt
about that but all right let's talk
about substance a little bit the big
thing was that Obama is saying
he's gonna do it alone if Congress won't
help him and he's gonna use executive
actions of course this has the
Republicans in a tizzy although five
years in Reagan used far more executive
orders as did Bill Clinton but do you
guys think it's sort of just bad
precedent and bad it's not even
precedent at this point it's been done
but is it just bad politics in the long
term to sort of be skipping a branch of
government even if that branch of
government is useless and has a seven
percent approval Junior I guess maybe
this is the shot out to the left or his
liberal base and doing it because this
is what people been asking not
necessarily this particular route about
it but at least to get more I guess to
have a stronger message towards this
branch of government that isn't doing
anything and maybe the one way around it
is to go with some executive orders
other than that is just to keep
browbeating them and tell them how much
they're not working and say well I'm
trying to work with you but then you're
not really working with me
what has been the constant narrative
it's not a time right yeah absolutely
and it's all he pulls him as is this
week president gets nothing
exactly all they do is block him and he
remains blocked they win so I think
really he's not losing much it's you
know basically he's gonna annoyed the
people who are already annoyed with him
for whatever reasons you have so there's
nothing to lose here yeah I think all
its gonna do is basically strengthen his
base get those people who are annoyed at
the gridlock back on his side and I
ideally you know backing those
Democratic new senatorial candidates
this year yeah so I'm agreed with you
guys on that that he sort of has to do
this because Congress is useless but if
it was the other side if this was a
Republican president doing this wouldn't
we all be pissed about this that he you
know if the Democrats were trying to
block his agenda which maybe we wouldn't
agree with wouldn't we all be pissed so
shouldn't we sort of have the same
standard regardless look if the
Democrats could be single-minded enough
to block anybody I guess that from the
hill then we could even debate like like
figure out that hypothetical but well
given how much we rolled over and played
dead or for during the Bush years you
know I don't I don't even know that it's
comparable yeah yeah again we'd have to
we'd have to create a whole different
mindset it's worlds where Democrats are
doing the same level of obstructions
going on now and we kind of sat and
watched President Bush and Vice
President Cheney run roughshod and do
whatever they wanted so we kind of saw
it happen it just wasn't with the same I
guess that the
same strategy in mind yeah isn't this
sort of a presidents dream because
Congress's approval is so low that he
knows that he can pretty much do
whatever he wants cuz everyone hates
them so he's sort of they've sort of
given by being so awful they've sort of
given him a great gift here haven't they
in a way yeah and I think when we once
we get past the midterms cuz he's still
that's the one last thing that he has to
sort of not ostracize too much of the
American public over once those babies
are over he is a man unfettered I can't
wait to see what Obama 2015 2016 is
gonna be like it'll work out great if I
think the other side of it is gonna be a
too full thing first he's gonna be
threatens with his more executive powers
but then he's pushing things like
immigration and saying are you guys
gonna really in coming up with 2014 are
you really gonna continue to fight
against immigration legal immigration
and people that already hear a lot of
publicans oh yeah they're starting to
worry no oh man we're not gonna get
elected if we keep fighting it's Latinos
oh this the gay rights agenda is moving
forward you starting to see some people
start to peel off because they're they
don't worry about actual policy they
care about their jobs so if he pushes
both those two narratives of I'm gonna
work harder and I'll make sure you guys
look worse in other ways other than just
saying you're lazy maybe it's gonna push
some of them yeah